in this video you're going to learn how
to find the maximum and minimums of a
graph using the difference quotient so
these are the turning points or the
bends in the graph or oftentimes
referred to as a relative maxes and mins
so let's get right into this video the
first thing we want to review is the
formula for the derivative okay which is
the difference quotient as H approaches
0 the limit as H approaches 0 so really
what this formula is it's a formula for
the slope of the tangent line okay to
the graph at a particular point and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
analyze this graph here f of X equals 2x
cubed minus 6x and we're going to try to
find out where that graph is bending or
turning so we can find those relative
maxes and mins and we can get a good
graph of this polynomial without
resorting to using our graphing
calculator so the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to do the
substitution I'm going to put X plus h
in for X okay so I'm just substituting
that in for X so that's going to give us
2 times X plus h cubed minus 6 times X
plus h minus f of X which is this
original function right here so I'm
going to put it in parentheses to take
that as a group okay like so and this is
all divided by H okay so now I'm going
to expand this binomial cube by using
Pascal's triangle and the binomial
expansion theorem so that's going to
give us x squared I'm sorry x cubed plus
3x squared H plus 3x H squared plus h
cubed minus 6x minus 6 H minus 2 X cubed
plus 6 X all divided by H right I'm
going to distribute the 2 into the
parentheses here ok so that gives us 2x
cubed plus 6 x squared H plus 3 sorry
plus 6 XH squared right you have to be
real careful with the arithmetic with
these problems you make a little mistake
it's going to throw your whole answer
off right okay and this is all divided
by H and then what happens we get a lot
of cancellation so the 2 X cubed cancels
with the 2 X cubed is 6x with the
negative 6x and then what we can do is
you can factor out an H out of what's
remaining here okay 6 x squared plus 6x
h plus 2 h squared minus 6 all divided
by H now the H is cancelled numerator
and denominator is these are multiplied
and these are divided and remember
though it's the limit
h approaches zero so if I put 0 in for H
that makes these terms that have an H
and them go to 0 and what we're left
with is 6x squared minus 6 now this is a
formula for f prime of x this is our
derivative which again remember is just
a formula for the slope of the tangent
line so the thing is is when the graph
bends ok so say for example the graph is
looking like something like this every
time that it bends the slope of the
tangent line is going to be 0 it's gonna
be horizontal like this so by taking
this and setting it equal to zero the
derivative we can solve divide both
sides by 6 and you can see that x
squared equals 1 right if you take the
square root of both sides you get plus
or minus 1 so this is 1 and negative 1
okay and then here's where students
sometimes make a mistake you want to
take the 1 in the negative 1 you want to
put them back to the original equation
not the derivative because we're trying
to find the location of these turning
points on the original graph the
derivative is just a formula for the
slope so if I put 1 in here I get 2
minus 6 which is negative 4 right and if
I put negative 1 in I get let's see
negative 2 plus 6 which is positive 4 ok
so I'm going to go over to our graph
here now I'm going to plot these points
1 negative 4 which is right there and
negative 1 positive 4 which is let's see
right there and the other thing I want
to do is I want to take this and find
the zeros by setting this equal to 0 so
if i factor out a 2x we get x squared
minus 3 and if we factor this as a
difference of two squares and set all
these factors equal to 0 now we get our
zeros at 0 and plus or minus root 3 so
that means it's going to cross the
x-axis at 0 square root of 3 is about
1.7 and also a negative 1.7 and then if
we look at the leading coefficient it's
positive right so that tells you that
the graph is going to go up to the right
okay that's the end behavior and it's an
odd degree which means it's going to go
down to the left so that means this
graphs going to look something like this
like that so we've got a pretty accurate
graph now before this before we learned
about derivatives we would be able to
find the zeros and be able to find the
end behavior but oftentimes students
wondered you know where does this graph
turn does it go way up here or does it
just go a little bit past x-axis like
how do I know where it's changing
direction and that's what we basically
tackled in this problem here using the
difference quotient which is the
derivative setting equal to zero because
that's going to be where the slope of
the tangent line is horizontal and that
allowed us to find those key points so I
hope this helped you understand how to
work with the difference quotient a lot
better subscribe to my channel Mauro's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon